good friend of mine in the higher
echelons of the political arena come to
me and talk with me about his concerns
he said I'm really concerned about
what's gonna happen at the camp there's
an election coming up and what I believe
is they're gonna use this camp as an
example of why we need to focus on
security they're gonna try and frame it
so that people there are violent they're
extremists and they need to be dealt
with in a really harsh way
this is unseeded mr. Tate right when I
see you back off here let's come across
Stephen Harper's Conservative government
has always been a racist government
against our indigenous people I'm
suspicious that they're trying to flex
their muscles because the only but a
small fraction of people actually vote
it only benefits probably 1% of all of
Canada and it's the 1% elite legally
it's your right I mean as as the person
nations people if this is your territory
to to represent that to anybody that
wishes to come into the territory or if
they want to do work in the territory to
settle that matter through the courts
people don't need that to prove that
this is our land and always pets in the
province and everybody else needs to
prove why they think they can access our
last
you